one of the hearings i chaired we had
testimony from a guy
uh name named dr epstein oh yeah i know
about it
um and he's a psychologist used to be
the editor of psychology today
he's an academic he's by the way not a
conservative he's a liberal democrat
who voted for hillary clinton and openly
supported hillary clinton and
and he did empirical research
on google's manipulative search outcomes
so it's interesting psychology
when you type in a search the
autocorrect
the auto fill in not the autocorrect but
what automatically populates
makes a huge difference
um and the first few stories that come
up
make a huge difference and there was a
dramatic differential
between when you typed in hillary
clinton it would auto populate goods
yeah all good things
when you typed in donald trump it would
auto populate bad things and the stories
that would come up
would be predominantly good stories for
hillary predominantly bad stories
uh for trump and what was interesting is
is
dr epstein did the study and he
concluded that in 2016
google's uh deceptive
search outcomes shifted 2.4
million votes to hillary clinton
and he said this as a hillary clinton
supporter but he was he was horrified
but he also
projected he said in 2015 he said big
tech
is getting worse it's getting more
aggressive they could move as many as 15
million votes
to the democrats in 2020 and and so i
think it's a
huge threat
[Music]
now that we've gotten the important
stuff out of the way let's talk about
big tech because you've been right in
the center of this thing
as you know i've been fighting it from
my from my garage for the last five
years
uh trump did this executive action uh
230 is the is the what do you call it
it's not it's not a bill it's a
so it's section section of a bill called
communications decency
right so basically what he did was strip
some protections from the big boys from
twitter
youtube and facebook now my personal
preference and i think we're pretty
close on this
the libertarian side is you don't want
the government running around sending
regulators to these companies because
that's not going to do good
but stripping protection protections
to me seemed like the right idea do you
agree was the right idea
is it enough is it not enough et cetera
so i think it is the right idea
it's something i'd been urging trump to
do for three years so i'm glad that the
administration did it
um listen i agree with your sensibility
nobody wants
government free speech police i mean
that would be a terrible outcome well
some people do
but nobody
who's not insane and that's a qualifier
we can talk about some more because
there are a lot of people that fall into
that category but
government free speech police would be a
terrible outcome but what big
tech is doing
it's deliberate it's conscious it's
naked
it's abusive and it's dangerous i think
it's the single biggest threat
to free speech and democracy we have in
this country
because big tech has become a monopoly
controlling the instruments of
communication and
you know i've chaired multiple hearings
in the senate on big tech censorship
and one of the hearings we talked about
a document that google had prepared it's
called the good sensor
so they prepared its powerpoint about 50
page long
and it talks about how the old vision of
the internet
was the free speech laissez-faire
internet where people could speak and
say what they wanted
and then it talked about the new vision
of the internet and this is google's own
words
is the european style censorship model
and by the way the four companies that
google identified as implementing it
were google youtube facebook and twitter
this is a conscious decision and and the
dangers are enormous so the question
is how do you fix it if it is a problem
we have a long discussion about
whether it's a problem although
they're not hiding it anymore yeah i
think most sane
people at this point would agree that
there even even people that disagree
with us politically on this
i think most people realize that the
extraordinary amount of power
is a problem one way or another so i
will
it's interesting the political debate
though one of the talking points of big
tech in the left is they don't engage in
censorship
and the reason they say that is they say
well there are no
objective data that prove we do
and it's you know there's the old
aphorism of the of the
guy who kills his parents and then
pleads mercy on the court because he's
an orphan
it's true there are no objective data
because big tech controls all the data
and they they there's zero transparency
zero accountability so you can use
anecdotes and i i've gone through lots
and lots of specific
anecdotes but every time you ask big
tech and i've done it in writing i've
done it in hearings
simple questions all right in the 2018
election cycle
how many posts from republican
candidates for office did you block or
shadow ban
how many posts from democratic
candidates for office did you block or
shadow ban
their objective answers to that i mean
there is a number yeah
and they know the number and they refuse
to answer it and then say there are no
data and and so how do you fix it
i think one way to fix it is getting rid
of the special immunity from liability
that big tech has that congress gave
them
so that's 230 right that's 230. and the
reason
230 was passed congress believed big
tech would be
a a neutral public forum
in other words it wasn't fair to sue
facebook for a comment made by
an individual commenter because it
wasn't they weren't the speaker it was
someone else and so that was
that was congress's reasoning so we're
going to give big tech this immunity
from liability because it's third-party
speakers and we want to see the internet
grow
well what's happened is big tech changed
their mind they said we're not going to
be
to use the the language of the google
document
the the laissez-faire free speech place
anymore we're going to censor well you
know what if they're going to silence
views they disagree
and promote views they agree with they
don't
deserve i don't believe as a public
policy matter a special protection
for liability there's also the antitrust
laws
google is a monopoly uh by any measure
big tech is richer stronger more
powerful
than att was when it was broken up under
the antitrust laws they're bigger than
bit than u.s steel was
a line from the godfather we're bigger
than u.s steel well they're bigger than
u.s steel
um and
that abuse of power so i've also you
want to talk about the real
what the trump administration did on
section 230 will be
challenged it's at the fcc there'll be
litigation
the real bite here is
federal antitrust litigation which which
i have
urged the president to pursue diverge
the vice president pursue i've urged the
attorney general to pursue i've urged
the chairman of the federal trade
commission to pursue i've urged the
white house chief of staff to pursue
i've urged the white house council to
pursue to to
force the transparency to get the
answers
and to stop their their their naked bias
are you worried though that as
we sit here right now in the middle of
july only you know three four months
before an election that insert in a
certain way that the ship has already
sailed the damage that they've done
and even if you could get everything you
wanted tomorrow past tomorrow
by the time the processes and the
systems are are
implemented congratulations the
elections passed uh
i am deeply worried about it one at one
of the hearings i chaired we had
testimony from a guy
named named dr epstein oh yeah i know
about it um
and he's a psychologist used to be the
editor of psychology today
he's an academic he's by the way not a
conservative he's a liberal democrat
who voted for hillary clinton and openly
supported hillary clinton and and he did
empirical research on google's
manipulative search outcomes so it's
interesting psychology
when you type in a search the
autocorrect
the auto fill in not the autocorrect but
what automatically populates
makes a huge difference
and the first few stories that come up
make a huge difference and there was a
dramatic differential
between when you typed in hillary
clinton it would auto populate good
yeah all good things when you typed in
donald trump it would auto populate bad
things and the stories that would come
up
would be predominantly good stories for
hillary predominantly bad stories
uh for trump and what was interesting is
is
dr epstein did the study and he
concluded that in 2016
google's deceptive
search outcomes shifted 2.4
million votes to hillary clinton
and he said this as a hillary clinton
supporter but he was he was horrified
but he also
projected he said in 2015 he said big
tech is getting worse it's getting more
aggressive they could move as many as
15 million votes
to the democrats in 2020 and and so i
think it's a
huge threat if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure
to subscribe and click the notification
bell